[Musique]
bonjour les 12 et 19 juin auront lieu
les élections législatives
c'est une échéance décisive pour notre
pays en effet c'est à l'assemblée
nationale que ce vote les principales
lois les principales réformes pour les
cinq années à venir et nous avons
vraiment besoin dans notre pays d'une
assemblée nationale qui puisse être
libre indépendante qui puisse
véritablement constituer un
contre-pouvoir en effet aujourd'hui il
faut pas concentrer tous les pouvoirs en
une seule main c'est dans cet esprit que
j'ai décidé d'être candidat pour être
votre et débuté dans la première
circonscription de côte-d'or je veux
véritablement être votre voix à paris et
non la voix de paris sur le territoire